[Musique]
par la drogue il s'évade un monde de
bulles ans qu'ils ont volontairement
quitté pour des rêves artificielle
côtoyant sans la subir
l'effroyable réalité de la misère la
détresse de ceux qui n'ont pas choisi de
sur vivre ou de mourir sur les trottoirs
de calcutta
[Musique]
m
on
[Musique]
dans lesquels vide de l'inde immense et
pauvres ils ont cherché un refuge pour
enfants de pays riches touristes perdus
et transhumants dix mille jeunes environ
européens et américains en rupture de
sociétés ont recréé sur les plages
paresseuse de goa une vie tribale d'un
autre âge parmi eux une majorité de
français jeunes pour la plupart bernard
cordier médecin coopérant au consulat
français de bombay est souvent le seul
lien entre la familia société le jeune
hippie il vient leur rendre visite
lorsqu'un cas graves est signalé ou
lorsque les parents inquiets demandent
une enquête
des parents ils essaient d'obtenir
argent oubliés dans l'avion pour un
retour éventuel mais ses moyens sont
minces face à la tuberculose à l'ami
biase à l'hépatite à la malnutrition et
aux accidents dus aux excès de drogue
minces face à l'obstination désabusé des
jeunes dont certains comme des clochards
vivent à l'abandon sur ses plages
discret jeune caractériel fragile
inadaptée traumatisés par des
difficultés familiales ou
professionnelles en fuite vers une vie
sans responsabilité sorte de ras-le-bol
une envie de tout laisser tomber de
partir comme ça généralement ses secrets
c'est à peu près pareil voyage
sorte de fugue et justement cela qui qui
fut quelque chose en venant à goa sont
généralement déçus et leur situation se
dégrade très rapidement
en inde si bien sur le plan financier
que sur le plan légal et je vois arriver
au consulat reçus dans un état pitoyable
en tout cas c'est courant mais nous
pouvons passer après parce qu'il joue
bien et je suis de succès
et je compte rentrer
ce qu'aucune du bouquet parce que
j'avais comme étant sa taille dans la
soie trois jours prochains jours et
comme étant carrément s'affaissant
forcément et demi la réunion était je
monte mon avis chez léo n'est pas le
seul mot 69e ça c'est pas son geste à
problèmes par deux passeports des trois
tiers un bal 16e depuis un mois la
plupart ont vendu leurs passeports à des
trafiquants 400 francs pour un passeport
français
ainsi ce procureur jean et drogue sur la
route qui les mène d'europe en inde en
passant de camions autobus par la
turquie l'iran l'afghanistan et le
pakistan
cette route gérard 24 ans la fête
jusqu'à katmandou écho à depuis cinq
mois
comme tant d'autres à la recherche de
nouveaux horizons
attiré par la tolérance parfois monnayer
de la législation indienne envers les
drogués qu'est-ce que tu participes ans
d'existence
rock beaucoup
pas mal pas mal on en sait comment
nucléides
je crois que là
comme ça dans la morphine la cocaïne
m'enfin ici ce qui a surpris c'est la
mort la compagnie
le hsv
et l'héroïne aussi parce que tout le
monde se drogue dans les jeunes pop a
dit je peux pas dire j'ai pas du tout le
monde dans les médias
c'est pas mal non
qu'ils se défoncent
sur ces plages sans règles et sans loi
ils vivent de rapine de petits trafics
ou d'un mandat providentiel tous fument
du haschich robes douces qui ne coûte en
inde que 20 prend lady g 12 prend une
pilules de lsd
le trafic se fait au grand jour et fumé
du haschisch est un rite un signe de
reconnaissance entre eux hippie de tous
pays et de toutes classes sociales
la drogue sur les visages laisse des
traces
comme sur celui de françois qui n'a pas
encore 25 ans
une fois les drogues qu'est-ce que les
drames humains
c'est les drogues
le café sortait son
n'importe quoi
le ben non
quelle drogue
[Musique]
si ça vous permet de développer vos
facultés
fois faire et si ça vous permet de
de vous organiser
[Musique]
j'ai rien bourget
mais derrière les douches humeur 2 h 30
pour cent des jeunes s'adonnent aux
drogues dures à l'héroïne à la morphine
à tous les dérivés de l'opium et vivent
terrés au fond des plages réseau étroit
de junkie qui trafiquent les utilisent
la drogue venue du triangle d'or via
bangkok un gramme d'héroïne vaut ici 250
francs des prix imbattables
chaque année une trentaine de hippies
meurent d'overdose sur les plages de
bois
d'autres comme ce jeune suédois sombre
lentement dans la folie les 354 henvic
son passé noir à lombez j'ai eu des cas
mais terrible j'ai vu du début des jeux
passion penser à un jeune garçon des
ventes est passé le voir est arrivée en
courant consulat apeuré pleurant y
assistant millions d'indiens qui me
poursuivent qui m'en veulent protéger
moi je pense à celui qui s'était enfui
la tête dans le sable en recherchant le
diable centre la terre
j'ai plein de cas comme sa régie aussi
des au mois de décembre il y en a un qui
est mort de faim c'est à dire qu'ils
avaient
et la prolonger son jeune
interposés 26 kg et puis est mort de
cachexie
[Musique]
ce médecin de bombay pourra peut-être
rapatrier 10 20 heures que la drogue et
la déchéance ont rejeté aux limites de
la folie mais que deviendront-ils
ensuite le paradis de goa est un mirage
et le mouvement hippie n'offre plus que
des fleurs vénéneuses
[Musique]